for a third time if wesley gives a check
yes i think they will
and but this wouldn't be that this would
be the second time right this will be
the second time if wesley brings his
queen back to where it came from
onto the f line to pin the white bishop
but if that happens actually
i think i figured out why white was
winning i wanted to suggest it but i
wasn't entirely sure
if the queen comes back white pawn white
central pawn just push it up the board
it's supported by the white queen and
actually it's a runner it's gonna sprint
up the board
so wesley maybe realizing he shouldn't
repeat the position
if he repeats he's just bluffing he's
going for the draw but
um it's actually a blunder if wesley
puts his queen back
where it came from but it doesn't seem
like liam has seen it
i think he just wants to repeat once he
wants to okay he's repeated it he just
wants to gain 20 seconds on the clock
liam but
he he goes for the draw he was actually
winning in the final position
okay liam escaping there with a draw low
on the clock but
missed opportunity wow okay liam obvious